PAUL IRISH: Welcome to The
Breakpoint with Paul Irish and
Addy Osmani.
Today we're gonna show you some
cool stuff inside the
DevTools, tell you a little
bit about hardware
acceleration, and hopefully
teach you about some
JavaScript language tooling that
should really help your
kind of team productivity
and ability to
maintain large products.
So first off, we're gonna kick
off immediately with a demo.
And if we go to my screen, I'm
gonna show Wikipedia here.
So we have just a standard--
this is the Wikipedia
page for Wikipedia.
Now what I want to do is I want
to look at how it loads.
Some people on the Chrome team
were actually looking at this
on the Nexus 7 tablet.
And it has a little bit of
a weight as the page is
[INAUDIBLE].
So, actually if I just
load the page--
I'll get rid of the
DevTools for now--
and I'm moving my hands
on the track pad
to scroll it a bunch.
You can see it's--
OK, I kind of missed
my target.
But there's a good three second
delay as the page is
loading before it starts
getting responsive.
You can test this out
yourself right now.
But what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna show that in the
DevTools timeline.
So, let's hit Record.
And now I'm gonna go back
and refresh the page.
And we're waiting
for the spike.
There it is.
All right.
So right here, this
big yellow spike.
So yellow is JavaScript inside
the timeline here.
And if I scroll down a bit--
if there's too much blue for
you, you can always just
uncheck the blue on the very,
very bottom down here.
I'll do that for now.
And you see this guy here.
So this is a 3.5 second frame,
3.5 seconds where the
browser's not responsive
to the user at all.
So, this is pretty
interesting.
So we have these three big
yellow blocks where it looks
like we're evaluating
script over here.
Let's open them up.
And looks interesting.
So we have kind of this
waterfall look where there's a
few things going on.
And if you look over on the
right-hand side, it looks like
a lot of recalculate style,
recalculate style.
Here we have recalculate
style going back
and forth with layouts.
So this is the situation called
layout thrashing.
For right now, let's focus
on this layout style--
sorry, recalculate style.
So, the fact it's doing the same
thing over and over again
is usually an indication
to you that
something might be wrong.
And we can find out what's
going on here.
So if we just hover in this
area, we get the tool tip.
And we get the actual call
stack on why we're
recalculating the style.
First, our layouts were
invalidated at some point
during the add embedded CSS.
And then our recalc was
forced, again, in
add embedded CSS.
OK.
Interesting.
So, if I click through, well,
it's all minified, but we can
address that.
So I'm gonna click the pretty
print on the very bottom.
We pretty print.
And just to make sure that we're
looking at the right
spot, we're gonna go back
to timeline and
click through again.
And here we go.
So we're looking at embedded
CSS right here.
And it jumped me to this
line actually.
So what add embedded CSS is
doing is Wikipedia loads a
bunch of its modules into the
page kind of lazily as this
page is loading, and then
if there's any styles
associated with it.
So they actually have like
a little tool tip module.
And they load in jQuery
UI for a widget
farther down the page.
And then CSS needs to
go into the page.
And, in order to deal with a
IE bug where you could only
have up to, I think, 32 style
sheets per page, they reuse an
existing style element.
So it's an inline style element,
and they just append
more content into the
bottom of it.
Which makes sense if you only
have a maximum of 32 possible
style sheets available to you.
But it doesn't make a lot
of sense otherwise.
So here we have, basically,
there's a few techniques for
adding in new styles.
One is using stylesheet.csstext
which is
only supported, I
think, by IE.
But that might have changed.
And otherwise, we create a
little text node, and we just
inject it into a
style element.
Basically the same thing.
But what these two techniques
do is it just says to the
browser, hey, you know all those
styles that you were
keeping tracking of and you knew
the computed style of all
the elements of the page, throw
all that out because I
just changed the world and
you're gonna have to
recalculate everything else.
And so this, if we look at the
timeline, happens about 20
times or so as the
page is loading.
And so the browser is just doing
all this work again and
again and again, doing the
same recalculation of the
style with a very small little
difference at the end.
And it turns out WebKit
actually--
we were digging into this
and we looked through
the source of WebKit.
WebKit actually has a fast path
for if you're just adding
a few new actual styles at
the end of the document.
And it doesn't have to
recalculate the world.
It can just kind of augment
what it knows
with the new styles.
And it's fast.
But here, we're clearly not
hitting this fast path because
every single recalculate is
taking, wow, 130 milliseconds.
When a frame is 16.6
milliseconds, 130 milliseconds
is a long, long time.
So this is a bit of a problem.
But luckily, we've gotten in
touch with some of the
developers at Wikipedia and
Wikimedia to adjust this.
And we've fixed it
in two places.
So one is this recalculation
of style.
Like I said, these come
in from modules.
And so one of the approaches
that we did is we just batch
it all together, right.
We have new styles come in from
seven different places.
Let's just smush them all
together into one string and
inject it at once.
And so then we can basically
take these 20 recalculations
of styles and bring it down
to about five or so.
So that's a really big win.
The second is we're not gonna
continue to augment an
existing style tag, instead
we're going to create new
ones, except in the
case of IE.
IE 6 through 9, where that style
sheet limit is still in
force, we'll still continue
to do this little trick.
Lastly, I wanted to show this
kind of layout thrashing.
So, what we can see, actually,
on a hover of the layout where
we have the little icon--
so the icon is there because a
forced synchronous layout is a
possible performance
bottleneck.
And so what this
means is that--
so we see that the layout
was invalidated because
we added new stuff.
But the layout was
forced here.
Basically, browser needs to
deliver what the geometry of
the page is to where we
are in this curCSS.
This is actually inside
of jQuery.
So if we look down, it looks
like our loader that is bring
in these modules is
doing some stuff.
It's now injecting some
styles into the page.
And now we're going
through jQuery.
And looks like we have to
augment with our height.
And if I click in this curCSS,
yes, I just used
get computed style.
And we're about to
figure out what
the style is of something.
So apparently, right inside
here, we have to do something
that looks like we're setting
the width of the page or the
height of an element.
And in order to do that in
jQuery, it needs to use get
computed style.
So basically, the browser
says, stop everything.
Let me get this value.
OK.
Here you go.
And then immediately after that,
we're gonna recalculate
all the styles again and
again and again.
So there's a few ways
to address this.
In this case you can get all
your truth out of the DOMs.
You need to get computed
style.
You need to get an offset
top, et cetera.
Do those all together, and then
make changes to what the
styles of the page should be.
That's probably the best
way to handle this.
When you see a pattern going
back and forth like this, you
know that it could be better.
So.
Anyways, the good news here is
every page on Wikipedia was
slow before.
And the fix actually should
be rolling out
within a week or so.
And so you should be seeing a
benefit and be able to scroll
immediately on both desktop and
on tablet immediately upon
loading the page, which I'm
real excited about.
So Addy, how's it going?
ADDY OSMANI: Really awesome.
So, I'm gonna be talking
about GPU acceleration.
Now, traditionally, browsers
have relied quite heavily on
the CPU for rendering pages.
And it's only in the last few
years that we've realized that
involving the GPU in compositing
those pages can
yield us some really nice
performance benefits.
In Chrome, we've actually for
a while now had this concept
of a composite layer for
minimizing repaints and
basically using GPU
acceleration.
And the idea is if you're
using something like
Translate3d with a WebKit
transform, that'll get
promoted to a composition layer
before it gets animated.
Now, GPU acceleration of your
DOM elements has a number of
different benefits.
It's a little bit more efficient
to draw things to
the screen.
And you avoid issues like
hopping over really large
amounts of data from the
video to system memory.
So I'm actually gonna show you
an example of a site that's
taking advantage of
GPU acceleration.
And it's this nice
demo by David
DeSandro called Undulate.
So the idea is I move my cursor
around and I get this
really nice fluid animation.
If you open up your DevTools
and you go to Settings,
there's actually a really nice
feature the gives you insights
into what DOM elements are being
manipulated at a GPU
level called Show Composited
Layer Borders under Rendering.
So I go and I enable Show
Composited Layer Borders.
Now what you can now see is
around each of the circles on
screen, there's a little golden
border indicating that
that element is being
manipulated at a GPU level, or
that it's using hardware
compositing.
Now that's really awesome.
Just to confirm again, remember
I was talking about
translate3d with a WebKit
transform earlier, and that's
basically what they're
using here.
So I've just shown
you Undulate.
And the next example I'm gonna
show you is Isotope, which is
another plug-in by
David DeSandro.
Now, if I go into my DevTools
and I enable Show Composite
Layer Borders once again, what
you'll notice is that all of
these elements, they're taking
advantage of GPU acceleration,
every single one of these.
And that's helping
in this case.
This is actually using, once
again, WebKit transform with
translate3d.
And it's doing it properly.
Another thing you may have come
across for the past few
years is something called
a null transform hack.
Now the null transfer hack
basically allows you to force
GPU acceleration of a DOM
element, meaning it's gonna
get promoted to its own
composite layer.
Now, a few years ago this hack
was a lot more relevant.
It basically gave you some great
mileage in your page
whenever you found
that it was slow.
And it played its part.
But Chrome has been getting
much better at handling
compositing in the background
for you so that you don't have
to use hacks like these.
However, there are gonna be
cases where you might get a
little bit of mileage
out of it.
Be careful when you're
using it.
The only case where I suggest
actually using translateZ is
where you have a measurably
high paint
cost on a DOM element.
So if you have a measurably high
paint cost, you've used
timeline, you've used our other
tools to figure out if
there's a high paint cost on a
DOM element, then maybe tryout
the translateZ hack and see if
you get some mileage from it.
One other demo that took
advantage of the translateZ
hack is Google Space
by Mr. [? Dube. ?]
Now, what he found was that he
was animating this stuff in
his page, and it was just going
really, really slow.
He wasn't really sure why.
And he took advantage of the
null transform hack.
And basically, I've got
composite layer borders on at
the moment, and look
what happens.
It's now animating a little
bit more smoothly.
You can see the composite layer
borders are on each of
our elements.
And it's a little
bit more smooth.
It's a little bit more buttery,
and that looks good.
You have to be really, really
careful when you're using the
null transfer hack, however,
because if you go and you
apply it to every single element
in your page, you're
basically gonna offload a
whole lot to the GPU.
You have a limited amount of
VRAM on desktop, on mobile.
And you just want to make sure
that you're not bursting that.
It's less likely that it's gonna
happen on desktop, a lot
more mobile.
And I'm actually
gonna show you.
So, The Guardian is a website
that performs sort of OK.
So this is like a newspaper
in the UK.
And this site performs sort
of OK on desktop.
If I go back into sort of my
DevTools, I've got Show
Composite Layer Borders on.
And I go and I add basically a
null transform to everything
on the page--
so WebKit transform
translateZ(0).
What you'll now see is that
there is a composite layer
border being drawn around
everything 'cause it's all
being promoted.
And this page is actually gonna
run a little bit more
slowly than it was before
because absolutely everything
is being offloaded to the GPU.
That's not a good thing.
Now let's take a look at what
this does on mobile.
So, I've got my Android
phone with me.
I've got Chrome beta
currently running.
So this is the experience.
So let me show you
what I've got.
This is what the experience
looks like without me enabling
the null transform hack
on absolutely every
element on this page.
So I'm scrolling through.
Their mobile experience is
actually pretty decent.
You see I'm able to scroll
through the entire page.
And it's not too bad
to be honest.
Let's go in, and let's see what
happens if I actually
enable this hack.
So, WebKit transform
translateZ(0).
And now watch.
It actually takes a
while to scroll.
I know it's, again, subtle,
but it's actually taking a
while to scroll through
this page.
It is not as smooth
as it was before.
And so you need to be very
careful whenever you're using
the translateZ hack.
You don't want to
blow your VRAM.
You don't want to put too much
pressure on your GPU.
Now, for people that are
wondering why isn't Chrome
trying to do more of this stuff
automatically for me?
Why are people still needing to
use these translateZ hacks?
So if you go to Chrome Flags,
you can actually take a look
at some of the work we've been
doing to further compositing.
And there are actually two
experiments in particular that
you can go and you
can play with.
You can enable GPU compositing
on basically all of the pages
that you browse on.
And you can actually also enable
threaded compositing
which gives you an additional
thread for web page
compositing.
And it just gives you things
like smooth scrolling, even
when the main thread, which is
where a lot of the action
happens, is unresponsive.
So go and play with
those things.
We're currently still
benchmarking performance of
compositing across all pages.
But in most cases, it's actually
gonna perform pretty
well, at least as good as using
the translateZ hack
across all these elements
on your page.
So the takeaway from this is
be very careful when you're
using null transfer hacks
in your pages.
Make sure that if you're
applying them that you have a
measurably high paint cost on
those DOM elements where you
are applying them.
And just be careful when
using these things.
Make sure to measure.
Measurement is the most
important thing when you're
doing any sort of performance
optimization on your pages.
So, yeah.
That's it for me.
PAUL IRISH: I was just gonna add
on a few things to that.
There's been a few updates in
kind of the compositing
situation in Chrome.
So, for any composited layers,
if you've taken like a DIV
before and rotated it 45 degrees
and you had text
inside there, you might have
noticed that the text quality
is not so sharp.
So, it'll now look great as
long as that DIV has a
background.
So that's a somewhat recent
change, probably about two
weeks ago or so.
So it's opaque composited layers
get anti-aliasing.
The other is that fixed position
layers are now
composited for you automatically
in a few
situations.
One, if you're on Android,
then it's done for you.
On desktop right now, it's in
many cases you may have to use
something like the null
transform if it's a situation
where it really has benefit.
In high DPI situations.
So you're on your retina machine
or on another laptop
with a really high resolution,
a Chrome Book pixel even, any
fixed position layers are
now composited as well.
So you're gonna see the same
kind of performance increase.
So it's a really good thing.
And this will be coming to
situations where it's not high
DPI very soon once we can get
text anti-aliasing on these
layers as well.
So, we want to make sure the
type looks good before we flip
the switch and give the
compositing performance boost
to everyone.
So, that's kind of the update.
Lots of things have
been changing
in this area recently.
So, there we go.
Lastly, I wanted to show
just a few slides.
And this is some great stuff
that a lot of this comes from
work and research done
by Ariya Hidayat.
And Ariya created Esprima,
also created PhantomJS.
He's a platform architect
over at Sencha.
But there's a lot of great
tools now available for
JavaScript language authoring
and editing, debugging,
continuous integration.
And I want to show
a few of them.
And the first thing that I want
to say is that a lot of
teams set up style guides,
especially for JavaScript.
And I think this is
a great thing.
And I think that things like
JSHint have really allowed us
to have maintainable rules that
we can kind of agree on
and say for this project,
this makes sense.
And so, the most important thing
I think is that every
code style rule that
you have, it should
be backed by tooling.
So you should not say something
about your use of
commas or spaces around
assignments that you cannot
enforce with tooling.
Because it's a waste of our
time, like human's time, to be
worrying about style inside
our JavaScript.
And I see this in open source
or poll request.
And the first comments will be
like, yeah, well, put some
more white space here.
It's not a good use
of our time.
So, I'm gonna show a few pieces
of tooling that exist
for this sort of thing and other
pieces of JavaScript
authorizing.
First, a little bit ago, I
think back when I was in
London, Addy and I, and we had
on Sindre Sorhus, and he
talked a little bit about a
few of the project level
collaboration techniques.
So one is setting up a
gitattributes file where you
specify * text=auto.
Make sure that your line
endings are good.
Do it.
That's great.
EditorConfig has gotten new
enhancements since we talked
about it last.
So it used to only define
how end of lines are
done, indent style.
It now covers things like a
extra line at the end of the
file, a few other things.
They're all really good, the
kinds of defaults that you go
up into your editor to make
sure that you apply.
No trailing white space.
Things like that.
So, that's great for all code,
not just JavaScript.
And really makes just
collaboration easier.
Rules can be set per project.
JSHint, which I just
mentioned.
In a jshintrc file you
can define your
rules for the project.
And every Sublime Text
and the VIM plug-ins
all honor this file.
Grunt, as well, honors this
file if it's placed in the
root of your project.
So that even if a project
differs from another one, you
can define what your JSHint
settings are, and everyone
that's collaborating there
will honor them.
It's really good.
So a few more things that are
available for JavaScript
language tooling.
So this is a use of a precommit
hook inside Git that
will validate that your code
is syntactically correct.
So, we're using a binary
called esvalidate.
It uses Esprima, that's
a node binary.
And basically, this just makes
sure that you cannot commit to
Git unless esvalidate
passes it.
So this is not a linter.
This is just a validator.
So it's just like everything
is syntactically correct.
It matches ECMAScript
standards.
Plato is a fantastic project.
So this is a visualization of
Plato data, but it exists is a
node binary as well.
Gives some ideas around
maintainability index, an
estimated number of bugs,
which is a kind of
controversial idea.
But it has a lot to do with the
cyclomatic complexity--
whatever that means-- of
code, lint errors.
And so you can kind of
get a sense for--
one of the things I think is
really interesting is taking
something like the
maintainability index and
charting that over time and
kind of a continuous
integration thing.
So being able to see that over
the life of a project and to
know that when some big new
feature landed in, the code
inside the project got
significantly more complex and
hard to maintain.
I think that's a fantastic
thing to kind of
visualize for the team.
This is a Boolean trap finder.
So, Boolean traps is an API
design flaw where you use a
Boolean in your API
to define that.
So in this top one, this is
a real-world example.
New slider false actually means
that it should be a
vertical slider and not
a horizontal slider.
Bad API design.
This could be much better.
You pass in an object that says
vertical equals true.
And we can just detect all these
across the project and
make sure that we aren't doing
something like this.
So, polluting variables.
So, if we have a variable that
we don't define in at least a
global, we should be notified
immediately.
JSHint captures much of this,
but using, in this case,
node-leaky does this by
using Esprima as well.
Always smart to check.
I've seen a few projects that
have changed their style guide
and said we were all double
quotes, and now we're
switching to all
single quotes.
And it's a little bit hard to
search and replace for.
But tooling can actually just
tackle this completely 'cause
we can just parse the text
into a JavaScript AST, or
abstract syntax tree, change
all of our quotes, and then
code generation it back
into our source.
And we can be confident that
it will still be completely
valid JavaScript.
Copy paste mistake detection.
I believe this is actually
already in WebStorm.
So let's say if I copy this
first line here, paste it down
here, and I'm changing the
x1 to x2 but I forget
to do it over here.
We had a pretty bad bug in
WebKit for one day where
someone did this.
It's almost exactly this
code example, and it's
a copy paste mistake.
So this can now be detected.
And you can be notified.
It's a really smart thing.
Like I was talking about style
guides, CodePainter is a tool
that can reformat the JavaScript
that you're working
on to fit a style guide.
So, single quotes, double
quotes, white space around
arguments, things like that,
CodePainter can just do the
formatting for you, which I
think it would dramatically
change a lot on how people
collaborate on projects and to
worry about things like style.
This is Travis.
So Travis CI I is a free
hosted, open source,
continuous integration setup.
So, this is a Dojo 2 running
inside Travis.
So on every commit to this
repository, Travis goes pulls
down the latest, installs a
bunch of node dependencies,
and then it connects up to Sauce
Labs, which has a lot of
browsers in the cloud.
Connect up with these browsers
using Selenium.
And then we execute a test
suite inside all these
browsers, so Firefox and
Internet Explorer, and running
our test suite just
to make sure that,
indeed, everything passes.
Really powerful stuff to get
that immediate feedback of for
every single commit, how am I
doing against all my platforms
and all my test suites with
every commit and every poll
request, too.
Right now, Travis will come
back and give you a little
badge and say all
tests passing.
I'm excited about other products
doing this too using
something like the GitHub's
commit status API.
So, for instance, for meeting
style guidelines or meeting
performance goals or not
making sure that that
maintainability complexity
thresholds are not violated.
We can get that kind of
feedback immediately.
And it should all be automatic
because we as humans should
not be testing these things
manually on every single time
and can let the tooling
support this for us.
So I think we have a little
bit a room to grow there.
So this is JIRA.
But this is just a view of all
the things that I just
mentioned could be looked at
over time over the life cycle
of a project in a continuous
integration environment.
And the last one I have--
not really related but
I think it's cool--
so this is fighting-layout-bugs
is a CSS
testing tool that can be used
inside of a continuous
integration setup.
It integrates very
well with Maven.
So if you have a Java stack,
it's great for that.
And so it does a few things.
It detects some common layout
bugs where you might have made
a mistake in the CSS or
might have not tested.
So take for example
DetectTextNearOr
OverlappingVerticalEdge.
And so what this does
is it actually just
looks at the page--
and I think it uses PhantomJS,
I believe--
and finds situations where text
overlaps or goes right up
against another element in a way
that the software thinks
is incorrect.
And it will highlight it to you
to hopefully be like there
might be a layout bug here.
This has actually been out for
about three years or so.
Some of these projects have
been out for a while, but
we're seeing a little bit more
adoption these days of them
which I think is really
good things.
So, I guess that's
about it for me.
How are we doing, Addy?
Does that all make sense?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
So we talked about snippets
a few episodes back.
And they're basically a really
neat way to create, edit,
store, or execute JavaScript
inside the DevTools.
So if there are like custom
utilities that you always like
having available at the console
or inside the tools,
you can just save those as a
snippet and always have them
available to you whenever
you restart Chrome.
Now I've got some great
news to share today.
Snippets are actually moving
out of experiments.
And that's gonna be happening
sometime soon.
We've also added a really neat
shortcut to snippets.
So if you have an existing
snippet and you just want to
run it without actually clicking
inside the interface,
there's a cool new keyboard
shortcut, which is control or
command plus enter.
So here I've got a snippet
called GrepJS by Nick Decosta.
It's a really nice
utility to have.
It'll basically grep over
different objects and find
things for you.
But, I'm basically grepping over
the navigator object for
geo because I'm looking for the
geolocation support in there.
So I'm basically gonna go and
use my command-enter.
And as you can see, it's
gone and it's run
my snippet for me.
I expand out, and I can see,
OK, well there's the
geolocation that I
was looking for.
It's just really neat.
I've seen a ton of people create
really useful utilities
and just saving them
as snippets.
It's great to always have
access to them.
So just check it out.
Snippets are really,
really awesome.
And, actually on this same page,
there is a post I was
hoping to suggest people
check out by my
colleague Paul Lewis.
And it basically discusses a
little bit more about those
layer creation hacks and
the null transforms and
translateZs and all
that stuff.
It's a really awesome post.
He goes into a lot more detail
about this stuff than I have.
But check it out.
We will link you up
to it later on.
But, yeah, it's really useful.
Paul also has a paint survey
out at the moment where he
asks developers do you have a
paint bottleneck in your apps
at the moment?
So far it looks like a lot of
people think they may have a
paint bottleneck but aren't
entirely sure how
to diagnosis things.
We're gonna be looking at that
stuff sometime soon.
And I think Paul's gonna talk a
little bit more about that.
PAUL IRISH: Paint cost
in another episode.
But we're really eager to hear
more from you guys on what are
your paint points when
identifying what is
contributing to paint issues,
both on mobile and desktop,
and figuring out how we can
better support you guys inside
the DevTools with good
solutions for that.
So, we'd love to get more of
your feedback regarding that
kind of stuff.
ADDY OSMANI: Defintely.
PAUL IRISH: Anyways, thank you
guys very much for watching.
It's been a pleasure.
And we'll see you again soon.